hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
do a q a sunday and what's going to be
happening right now you're in luck by
the way because i'm going to be
answering questions from last week's q a
sunday which is cool but the reason
you're in luck is because if you ask a
question right now in the comments below
next sunday i will be doing my best to
answer as many questions as i can from
you right now commenting so if you've
got a niggling burning question around
property investment tax mortgages the
economy making money comment below so
let's see what we had last week the
questions i've never done a q a sunday
video where i'm looking through the
questions thinking these questions suck
like you guys are just on it and your
questions i can tell that you're smart
following because of your awesome
questions so let's see what we've got
lewis clark joel berry craig all right
let's take some of these what does craig
say craig akerman he says hi samuel
since watching your videos and attending
the crash course last year i've been
buying properties using the brr strategy
boom good job man i'm glad you came to
the crash course and i'll be shortly
competing on my fourth property purchase
when refinancing i use interest-only
mortgages to maximize cash flow and
leverage as i'm looking to grow my
portfolio smart
at what stage in my property journey
would you advise to consider switching
them to a repayment mortgage or would
you just wait until the latter end of my
life and hope that the properties have
greatly appreciated over time and
potentially sell off some in order to
then use the profits to clear the debt
on the others keep up the great work
craig firstly congratulations sounds
like you've been doing it right brr is
buy refurbish refinance pull your money
back and then you can keep buying lots
of properties that way to answer your
question would i stop paying down the
mortgages personally i probably wouldn't
now i can't advise you on what to do
because what you do with your personal
finances is obviously your decision
myself so for the first 10 years of
investing in property i was just
interest only interest only interest
only and the reason for that is exactly
if you as you've said because if i'm
paying down the mortgages i'd rather
instead of using my money to pay off
mortgages i'd use that money to put down
on more deposits to then scale leverage
grow a bigger portfolio get more cash
flow benefit from more capital
appreciation for more houses so it just
makes sense and even like very very
wealthy people like robert kiyosaki
grant cardone like they
use interest only mortgages they're not
paying down their mortgages they're
still leveraging other people's money in
the bank's money so i think the answer
to you to your question is if you get to
a point where you don't want to continue
scaling if you're at a point where you
think you know what i don't want any
more houses i don't want to scale my
wealth anymore then fair enough maybe
stop paying down the mortgages for me in
2019 i did start paying off mortgages i
paid off so many mortgages and i also
started lending money and i almost got a
bit lazy and i thought i'm happy now i
don't need more money it was actually
grant cardone that called me out on this
in a in a private one-on-one mentoring
session and he was just like dude are
you over the hill now i was like i'm not
over the hill
he was like well you're not scaling big
anymore you kind of slowing down i was
thinking he's in his 60s
i'm still in my 20s
like if he's still leveraging and
scaling and growing and i'm now thinking
i've got enough houses now i'm going to
start being
maybe my mindset is wrong maybe i want
to you know i want to i want to be as
wealthy as i can not just for me so i
can have a lot of wealth so i can impact
more people so for me i'm more about
interest only and then at the end of the
term you can just sell off some of the
houses and pay off some of the mortgages
or renew or the world's your oyster
that's my personal plan so i hope that
helps thanks for your great question
good to see you kicking ass come back to
the crash course craig and let's
celebrate ben g fox says hi samuel my
question is what did you do different to
everybody else in the industry to become
a millionaire whilst others still are
not how did you build up your money
bench that's a really good question i
guess it's the millionaires question um
i became a millionaire i started out
investing in property and i wanted to
invest so i bought a property um
refinanced it the same day put it in my
stepdad's name because i was too young
to get a mortgage and i slowly started
using strategies like lease option
agreements i was managing properties to
try and get my foot in the door
and that's how i became financially free
how i became a millionaire believe it or
not was actually through deal sourcing
because once i'd become financially free
building my own property portfolio i
then thought okay i want to buy more
houses but i haven't got money and one
of the ways that i wanted to raise money
i thought well if i maybe find some good
deals and pass them on to investors
charge a fee i can use the fee to build
my own portfolio and i became really
good at that and i sold hundreds of
property deals charging
minimum of 2 000 pounds sometimes up to
7 000 pounds and that is actually how i
became a millionaire when i was 25 doing
that combined with my own property
investments and then i snowballed my
portfolio refinanced and continued
building it and that's how it happened i
think if you want to be a millionaire
you've got to work ridiculously hard um
you've got to invest and you've also got
to make money you've got to be an
entrepreneur and you've also got to be
invested together and when you row the
two alls hard
it can happen but it's not necessarily
for everybody however i do believe that
everybody can become financially free
meaning that they replace their job with
a property passive income and that's
really what i'm about teaching so i hope
that helps great question what's next
lewis edwards
hi samuel i'm 15 years old good for you
and was just wondering how do you write
a good business plan or maybe you can do
a video on it it depends what the
purpose of the business plan is is the
business plan for a for a bank because
you want to get a business loan is it
for an investor uh you want to get money
or is it for you if the business plans
for you i would i would i would
literally keep it really simple i'd
write down what are your personal goals
i.e i want to live in this kind of a
house i want to take this many holidays
a year i want to give this much to
charity what's your ideal
personal life look like and then how
much is it going to cost to finance that
personal your personal goals and that's
where your business goals come in okay
well property is going to be my vehicle
and i need x amount of money to fund my
personal life and now you've got the
amount of money it's not case of the
vehicle's property but how are you going
to get that money and it's just a clear
breakdown of exactly what you're going
to do you're also going to need to do a
risk assessment on the bad things that
can happen and you might think oh risk
assessment that sounds really
complicated it's not it's just write
down on a piece of paper all the things
that could go wrong and the ways that
you could lose money and then how are
you going to prevent that from happening
and how are you going to de-risk it best
you can so all this is is basically a
business plan and we do help people our
students on the academy we help them
write a business plan which which is for
their purposes but as i say depends what
the purpose is you're 15. um just get
just get right in one now and it's
really good to be clear on your goals
because most people that go into
property and they haven't got a business
plan it's good that you're saying this
you know i'm just going to start in
property it's like well what's your plan
if you haven't got a plan what do they
say if you plan to fail then you fail to
plan so good for you i hope you like the
video by now remember that's the first
step to being a millionaire smash the
like button all right next um
rick talon hi samuel just finished
watching your entire q a sunday playlist
wow that's that's commitment respect i
hope you liked every video
great content obviously i have a
question i hope to hear your take on it
for info i'm based in scotland would
like to use your local mortgage broker
tax accountant etc as scotland has a
divergent tax system or if investing
across the country use online brokers
solicitors etc
totally agree with agent nearby thank
you kindly paul
okay paul so i think what you're saying
is should you be using
local
should your power team i.e your
solicitors your brokers your accountants
be local to your house where you live or
should you be using people online that
are far away and the answer is a little
bit of both so of course as you've said
for your management company if they're
managing your properties
you want to be really close to your
properties your accountants your
solicitors your brokers doesn't really
matter i mean you might need to meet up
with them occasionally to sign paperwork
and stuff but generally speaking if
they're a couple of hours away it's no
problem just make sure you get on with
them make sure they're investing in
property themselves
and make sure they're solution finders
not problem finders so as long as they
understand what you're doing and they
understand the laws within your country
you can literally use people anywhere
and sometimes people are like i need an
accountant near my house you don't you
can use one a couple hours away it's no
problem so that'll be my advice hope
that helps
charles did you ever get your hands
dirty on any of your jobs i know my
hands look like kind of baby hands i did
i really really did i don't get my hands
super dirty very often now but actually
you know what when i started out in
property i worked on a building site for
six weeks i was i became a plasterer i
did lots of plastering um so in terms of
hands-on work i did do that and also
just getting my hands dirty by getting
really stuck in you know moving the
tenants in moving the tenants out i did
that for years i've been an estate agent
i've been a laying agent i've been a
plasterer i've been a negotiator so i
have got my hands dirty now
i still get my hands dirty when i have
to but
here's my general philosophy and i hope
this helps i think that whenever you're
doing something you need to be thinking
am i learning
am i earning
so you should probably get your hands
really dirty at the beginning because
you want to learn everything and then
once you know what to do then you're
going to employ people they're going to
do it for you but you know what they're
doing you get the role so
but for me right now if i was to go and
if if there was a
some plastering that needed doing for me
to go and do that plastering myself even
though i can do it wouldn't make sense
financially because my time is too
valuable i'd rather pay someone else to
do it but also in doing it i'm not even
going to be learning because i already
know how to do it i'd probably be
rubbish now anyway but that's kind of
how i look at stuff so i hope that helps
charles get your hands dirty in the
beginning make sure you've got good
people around you so you're doing it but
you're in a safe environment and then
replace yourself as often as you can in
business you always want to be replacing
yourself one aaron harat says i've been
trying to find a good rent to rent or
loi this option agreement property i'm
finding loads which could be good deals
but the problem is getting hold of the
landlord any advice on how to get hold
of the landlord all right so you're
finding load but you can't get hold of
the landlord where are you finding loads
are you just driving through the streets
thinking that would be a good house and
you want to get hold of the landlord are
you going on right move
where are you finding them listen if i
see a house i drive by a house and i
think
that's a good house you know and i want
to get in i go on land registry pay
three pounds and i'll get the details of
the landlord i'll get all the
information i need for three pounds if
i'm on right move you can find the
address just just zoom in and look at
the door number or there are ways on the
crash course we do it live so if you
know if you haven't meet your crash
course get on the crash course but
generally speaking for rental rents and
lease option agreements i find them in
places like gumtree on spare room on
open rents the landlord's details are
there if someone's advertising their
property to sell or to rent they're
advertising themselves
their number will be on the on there so
if you're finding it on these websites i
could within the space of 20 minutes i
could find over a hundred
contact details
for direct landlords and i just i just
go straight to gumtree and sparing an
open mind
i could [ __ ] the numbers and then i
could phone them up
and guess what probably about 10 of them
would be like no no no i'm not
interested and then one of them would be
like
okay this could work and then i'd jump
on the phone or do a viewing and then
that one would fall through
and then i have to find another 10 i get
another 10 rejections and then i'd get
another one they'll be interested and
then i get a deal so skill combined with
activity combined we've just picked up
the phone you know so i don't know if
that answered your question i hope it
did my seminars are not seminars okay if
you come to a property investors crash
course or any of my training programs
it's a do we know so aaron get down
we'll do it in fact i'm going to um
put a link in the description to the
property investors crash course
sometimes people say samuel the crash
course is too far it's so far
people come from australia
come from australia so don't be stopped
to the very first hurdle because if
you're stopped
by a three-hour car journey oh man
you'll be also stopped by those 10
rejections that you get you have like i
called three people and they said no
this doesn't work
and then you'll probably then you'll
probably start trolling my youtube it
doesn't work it doesn't work just put in
the activity man like you've got the
content you've got the information put
in the activity get in the right
environment
i love seeing you guys succeed i know
that's why you're here that's why you're
on my channel so listen let me ask you a
favor if you enjoy my youtube videos if
they're helpful please do smash the like
button also subscribe turn the
notifications on if you want me to
answer your question comment below and i
will be doing a video next week on
sunday at 7 pm and i'll be answering
your questions as many as i possibly can
thanks so much for watching also the
crash course if you want to book on the
crash course i'll leave a link
did you see that happen do you know what
why that's there because you need to
click it you need to book on it right
now go ahead go ahead go ahead i hope to
see you there god bless peace out
[Music]